كان عام 2006 موعدا لولاده موقع تويتر على
يد كل من جاك دورسي ونوكلاس وبيستون
وايفان وليامس ليتوسع عدد مستخدمه بشكل
مستمر واصبح متاحه للجمهور في نوفمبر عام
2013 بعد طرح اسومه في البورصه الامريكيه
ونهايه اكتوبر الماضي اتمنى
على شركه تويتر مقابل 44 مليار دولار
لينهي حاله جدلا وخلافات اندلعت بين
الطرفين كتب ماسك في تغريده الله الطائر
اصبح طريقا في اشاره تويتر لكن جدلا كبيرا
تار بشان مستقبل منصه ودورها وحريه
التعبير التي تدافع عنها غرض المالك
الجديد لتويتر قائلا ان النشطاء الذين
يثيرون مخاوف احيان طريقه الاشراف على
المحتوى على تويتر يحاولون تدمير حريه
التعبير في الولايات المتحده
ومساله المحتوى من نقاط الجدال وبينها نشر
الاخبار والمعلومات المضلله والتحريض
والحث على الكراهيه وكان من ابرز حضر حساب
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب على المنصه
بعد احداث اقتحام الكونغرس في 2020
وللمصادفه يعود الجدل باستحود ماسك على
تويتر وسط مخاوفا من تزايد المخاطر
الامنيه خصوصا مع اقترب الانتخابات
النصفيه
فوكلت بلومبرج اشارت الى منع وصول بعض
الموظفين في تويتر الى الادوات الداخليه
في الاشراف على المحتوى مما حدى من قدره
المنصه على التصدي للمعلومات المدرجه بشان
الانتخابات وعلى طريقه الرئيس دونالد
ترامب المثيره طرد ماسك جميع المديرين
التنفيذيين من طارق اجراول الى ساره وهي
كبيره مسؤولي العملاء في تويتر رغم ان عدد
مشترك الموقع يبلغ النحو 240 مليون وهو
اقل من ما هو الحال في منصات مثل فيسبوك
وتيك توك الا تويتر شكرت فضاءا رئيسا عاما
للناس للنقاش وسيله اتصال فعال لغلبيه
السياسيين وصناع القرار والمشاهير
والمؤثرين والصناع الراي والمفكرين وسعدت
المتظاهرين في التشبيك والضغط والحشد
والتنظيم والتعبير عن انفسهم في حديثه في
مؤتمر سيد هذا العام في فانكوفر قال ماسك
مبررا شرائه تويتر احساسي وحدث القويان
يخبراني ان امتلاك منصه عامه موثوق بها
الى اقصى حد وشامله على نطاق واسع امر
بالغ الاهميه لمستقبل الحضاره تلك مقاربه
ماسك وهو في نهايه مستثمر وتحويل منصه مثل
تويتر الى شركه خاصه ينطوي على مخاطر
عديده قد تمس ايضا الخصوصيه والبيانات
الشخصيه للمستخدمين
وقد يكونوا مصدر الخوف الاكبر ان يؤدي
استحواذ شخص واحد على منصه تويتر الى رهن
ابرز القيم الديمقراطيه التي تمثلها
المنصه وهي حريه التعبير
[موسيقى]